hello and welcome to inside Germany my
guest today was last year named as one
of the top 100 most creative people in
the business world you may not know her
but the chances are you've seen her work
it is Nadine Shaheen who is originally
from the Lebanon she is a typography and
especially in the Arab world her fonts
or typefaces are found all over the
place and they're also to be found here
on DW which will get rid of it welcome
to the show
first of all what was it like to be
named one of the top 100 most creative
people because type design is so
specialized and such a niche market and
this was completely mainstream and and
and I was so honored and and would not
believed it was it was amazing was it
nice for your profession to be sort of
recognized yes yeah yeah yeah especially
that they had never recognized the type
designer before so this was this was
nice and it was I think on behalf of all
the type design community was quite nice
as well to have type design being
recognized tell us what do you do what
is a typography into lay words you know
well what I do all day is I draw letters
and I design Funds typefaces font I the
software that you have on your computers
when you are writing a document in Word
and you want to choose if it's x or
Arial this would be these are the fonts
and my job is to design Arabic phones
okay that's good I want to ask you
though in your daily house yeah
because if you go to the supermarket
yeah and you're confronted let's say
with 50 jams 50 marmalades in front of
you would you buy one with a nice
typeface rather than the tastiest one
I mean how does it affect it it affects
definitely I mean I try not too much but
it's very hard to buy a product that is
not well designed package rice it like
the whole packaging has to look good and
typography is just one of the elements
but it will be it will be hard but then
in Germany the design quality is quite
high so it's not such a big problem in
the Middle East we have more issues and
if there's a typeface I hate on a
package it is is hard to buy even if it
tastes nice what maybe I don't know I
think it depends I mean I I'm a foodie
so I love food so I we will have to put
it to that aspect I think now another
one another what I want though that it
Latin script which is my script if you
like the English language or the German
language many others we write from right
sorry from left to right in Arabic from
right to left do you know why this is an
it's an issue of convention it's it's
simply just the same as deciding which
side of the road you want to drive on
the left or the right it's it's an issue
of convention and funnily enough there
was a point in time where Greek was
written in both directions so you would
start from one side and then the next
line you go the other way so it's quite
funny they had that kind of shape but
the most interesting thing in in reading
direction is that even though it is an
issue of convention if you look at
children after one year of reading they
will have what is called the directional
bias so when you grow up reading in the
English language which is the Latin
script you are reading from left to
right so after one year if I would show
you three bottles on the table and I
will ask you which one would you like
like pick up the first one you will pick
the one on the left because this is your
directional bias because you you view
the world from a left-to-right
perspective really if you go to the
Middle East where we read from the right
to left then is the other way around and
if I were to give you a piece of paper
and studies have shown this if I give
you a piece of paper and I say draw a
bow a boy kicking a ball because of the
way the language is structured in
English and it's the subject and then
the
and the reading direction is from left
to right you will draw the boy on the
left and the ball will be on the right
because the movement direction will
follow the script direction as well okay
now in German we we know having the
difficulty the verb is at the end yes
so does a German boy draw the ball on
the rise it will always be on the right
because that's the movement direction
okay cause you still do some
left-to-right
maybe he throws it all the way at the
end of the fifth yes but it's still the
same direction yeah okay now we
mentioned that you actually came to our
attention because you've been involved
in the typefaces and fonts of DW for the
Arabic programs now let's have a look at
some of your original proposals which I
I should say that this was in 2005 that
they're not yes possibly what's on the
Arabic programs now but can you I mean
this this looks quite difficult to us
you see ABCD on the right yes and what
was your brief from Deutsche Welle them
what did they want
so basically what they the most
important aspect of the brief was that
they need to communicate in the Arabic
language but at the same time keeps the
same brand identity that they have when
they are speaking in English or in
German so it is the same TV station
whichever language they are speaking in
and so when we go to speak in Arabic the
same personality that they project
worldwide needs to be projected in the
local script so that identity had to
stay the same so we had to look for an
Arabic typeface that would give the same
look and feel and the same identity the
same personality in Arabic that you
would have in Latin as well and with the
these were the original ideas yes okay
let's move on to the to what eventually
happened yes so yes I mean we had
different proposals we settled on what
we are seeing in the in the middle and
basically what the middle one here sorry
did so we know yeah yeah so so basically
what you're looking for it in a project
like this is to have harmony between the
Latin
the Arabic that when you put them
side-by-side when you write journal and
then in Arabic is Allah there needs to
be harmony between the different scripts
so you look for this same look and feel
you you search for this matching between
the two so you're not copying parts of
the letters in Latin and putting them
into Arabic no you design the Arabic as
if it's an Arabic typeface fully
authentic to what the Arabic script is
to expect but then the dressing up of it
is matching the same dressing up that
you haven't Latin okay now you mentioned
sure now that this is the end effect is
that this is now yeah yeah it's what
they accepted yes yes so when I saw it
they had Giornale written in English but
then there's also an option to have it
written in Arabic as well but yes
exactly and we have look at another one
this is tomorrow today exactly a science
program yeah exactly
and just a final one where is it where
is it there it is program I was 21
exactly yeah yeah so basically what
you're looking for here the kind of look
and feel is very modern is very
professional is something that is easily
accessible this is the kind of words
that you're looking for word and the
spirit that you want to convey and well
you I mean was it easy to work to this
end yeah yeah I mean it's it's it's sort
of what I do all day is it's not very
easy but then the process is really nice
and and we we had a really interesting
collaboration I came here to the offices
and had nice meetings and you know we
were supplied with graphics so we could
see how the typeface is going to look
next to the graphics because the
typeface is an ingredient is sort of
like your cooking and this is the salt
without the salt is never good except at
a dessert obviously but the main dish
right it needs the salt and this is the
typeface so but the salt on its own is
not enough it needs to blend with the
ingredients and this is what we were
trying to do here so we got the graphics
we supply test ones they could show it
and then they would send us back like
you know newsreels and like this is what
it's looking like this is what it looks
like when it moves on the screen
and this is the kind of thing that is
part of the design process so that's
what makes it so interesting it becomes
alive it's at first it's drawings in
black and white and then you use them
and it suddenly picks up its own
personality and that's that's the
enchanting files of type design okay now
we must move in country we've got a map
here of where you come from you come
from the capital Beirut yes and you were
born in 1978 which was the high point of
a civil war yeah so tell us what it was
like growing up oh my god well I mean I
was born in 78 the war started in 75 so
I was right in the middle of it and it's
that it stayed until 1990 so I had like
10 11 years of just like fully fully
engaging civil war and and we were
living in Beirut so we were right in the
middle so it's very hard to explain to
people sometimes what it was like
because when I was growing up I didn't
imagine in my head that there are other
people who did not grow up like this me
that this is how normal life is right
that there's bombs falling and the
school sometimes stops and people come
pick you up but that sort of thing and
and of course I mean it leaves an
impression
it wasn't 11 years non-stop because you
have different conflicts and different
parts of the city and different parts of
the country some conflicts we were not
affected and in some cases yes but it's
a very small country and and of course I
mean my earliest memories in life is in
82 they're Israeli invasion that's
that's my earliest memories in life and
and fleeing that is this this is a
picture on top of a car yeah with my
sister's this must well was that around
82 this would I say no this is before
that I would say this is 81 or 80
yeah yeah yes I'm not yet I'm still I
don't think in that picture I could even
walk I don't know maybe why don't I have
yeah yeah but and one more picture I
want to show of your family
actually now this is like this is your
father and yeah and and his wife and my
eldest sister there's also a middle
sister this is my defense last year for
the PhD so this is in later than Holland
in Holland okay that's the family there
they wrote is being called the Paris of
the Middle East anytime I mean why that
is we had the most western city in the
Middle East it is very Western Dubai is
very westernized as well so but like
historically speaking Lebanon had very
strong ties with France so it's called
the mother France and Beirut was always
this cosmopolitan city a lot of
foreigners come the main industry in the
country is tourism so we rely on
tourists from both the Middle East and
from Europe and the US and and so this
whole area was cultivated for that and
and you would have the night like we
still have the nightlife and you have
the you know the film styles and you
know like can almost and and so so
that's that's that's how it was we'll
talk more in a minute but you were back
there recently and you took one of our
cameras we have made this report let's
have a look at your hometown welcome to
my Beirut these are shots that I made
during a recent visit Beirut is a city
that is forever on the move loud noisy
busy and bursting with life every time I
go back there is something new to
discover and it is always this
interesting blend of east and west
they say that one of the most striking
aspects of the city is the churches and
mosques sitting side-by-side it's
certainly interesting to behold but it
has also gotten us into all sorts of
trouble for me it is more interesting to
see what people have to say outside of
these confinements in the streets where
we are just lebanese sometimes you will
find little kids selling flowers and it
is both sad and adorable and you just
wish that they would get a chance for a
better life this should be our focus
I am often asked what is the source of
inspiration for my work and I always
reply that it is the streets of Beirut
maybe not how it is today but how I wish
for it to be
and this is the little piece of heaven
in the city the American University of
Beirut I studied here for four years and
it is here that I grew up to be the
person that I am today and here that I
discovered what it is that I want to do
in my life I was so honored to receive
the Distinguished Alumni Award for my
work in Arabic type design it feels
different when you are on home ground
in 2004 I was asked by UB to design a
signage typeface for West Hall and here
it is
it is always a joy to come back to the
campus and to walk around with the views
of the Mediterranean and all agree how
can we not love it Beirut is a very old
city inhabited for thousands of years
and my favorite area is that the tips of
Beirut where the Mediterranean waves
crash on our shores the country is so
small and the sea is so open there is an
energy there that is simply enchanting
and maybe this is why so many people
come here to walk both in the morning
and evening hours young old rich who
from every part of the city they are all
here and this is the hope that the
country can come together to forget the
differences and the fighting and simply
enjoy what we have been given and to
work together for our one common destiny
it is extraordinary to see those
pictures if you look at the history
books and in recent history how much
civil war is taking place there and
devastation it looks such a wonderful
city and of course things can be rebuilt
but I wonder about the people you
mentioned hope there are the people of
the Lebanese people generally optimistic
yeah you have to be it's a way of
survival
I think they've we've had so much
turmoil in in like our history most
recent and the whole century that I
think it's a way of resistance that you
will always have this review that you
will have this joy for life and and you
want to go out and you want to have fun
and you want to live life to the max
because you don't know what happens
tomorrow and you have this spirit that
you do not want to get broken that that
you want to continue and live on and
when when bad things happen in Lebanon
we make jokes that's that's how I mean
it was just a few years ago spoted the
top place to visit by the New York Times
Lonely Planet travel guides name it as
that one of the top ten livelier cities
I mean yeah recommended people to go
there I mean the nightlife is amazing
the food is to die for you go there if
you want to pick up weight it's really
unbelievably good food fresh products
amazing and nightlife and and people are
so friendly and open that is really good
for visitors because we welcome people
because we are you know very small
country and we rely on tourists so we're
always welcoming anybody to come over
these days is a bit hard because you
know of the political situation but
generally yeah of course you
you've answered my next question what do
you miss obviously the what do you think
of German food are you should not ask me
I mean III like it in in small
quantities nots often because there's a
lot of fried things so I have to be
careful I'm a big fan of reinforced and
and they're ribbed well it's a sausage
sausage with beef beef sausage with
chili ketchup it's I could eat ketchup
yeah yeah good yeah well we have of
course curry curry Wurst here in Berlin
yeah yeah that's not too much did you
like sort of beef sausage with yeah just
the beef sausage was just a tiny bit of
sauce not too much and also glad
kartoffel
yeah roast potato while roast potatoes
aren't particularly yeah it's not like
saute to put it yes they do make it
quite a toes here it's always good yeah
I should ask you when you came to
Germany in 2005 and and why I was
offered a job so I came here in 2005
beginning of the year I was offered a
job at Linotype which is now we've
rebranded to monotype our mother company
name but I yeah I I was offered the job
here for six months I came and then one
month into it I was offered a full-time
job and I I thought I would stay for two
or three years and then I stood here
eight and a half years later so things
have worked out quite nicely is this a
photo it looks like in Germany it's
certainly no actually this is in this is
in Canada in Canada yes yes it's the
family so this is my two sisters the
four kids and the two husbands yeah but
then why are you standing on a railway
line
we weren't crossing and then I thought
you know me being artistic like this
would have a really nice perspective if
it was no bad intention I did not it was
nothing subliminal about it it just
looked nice with the perspective and
another photo yeah this is my best
friend Julia this is hidden germy this
isn't Frankfurt this was my birthday
years ago and have you found that you
you just said that you've stayed here
longer than you thought is that
partially because of making friends yeah
I mean the job is amazing so I it would
be very hard to leave because I love
working with the colleagues and and and
I have my perfect job but I also when I
when I thought I wouldn't stay was a bit
hard to have you know it takes time to
make friends here but then you know
after the first year I you start making
friends and I just love my friends here
they're amazing and and I such a nice
interesting group of different kinds of
people and and so it's like your family
here I believe that also shortly after
you arrived here really there's a
significant event in that the foot I
know you're a football fan but more than
just the football that the 2006 yes
football World Cup which was held here
in Germany yeah yeah it was it was very
special so I had been here a year and a
half and and then the football season
came and and it was it was amazing to
see because it was Germany being open
hospitable inviting everyone to come
whether you had a ticket or not just
come and join the festivities we had fan
fest
areas where you could go in in Frankfurt
was amazing we had because we have the
river mine and we had screens floating
in the river and you could sit on the
riverbank and watch the games and you
had all of these nice things around it
and was such a nice communal feeling it
was nice also in the transition for
Germany that they could pick up the flag
and and and and and and celebrate it and
it was it was a nice way to show the
outside world where Germany is and what
it is like to be here I mean we should
say that certainly for me I don't know
about as a Lebanese but we would be
waving thanks all 2006 yeah very
significant yes yes Germans wouldn't
have have had their flag putting out the
window before this was the first time it
happened they would actually articles
writing like being written at the time
commenting like that this is a
transition in the history of German in
recent history that that the showing of
the pride and
and the support of the teaming and all
of that was was really amazing and
you're right it did have an effect yes
outside Germany greatly or the attitude
absolutely absolutely both in the terms
in openness I mean everybody knows that
Germans know how to organize things very
efficient they know how to do things but
but this openness this was new and
unexpected and also very very warm to
welcome everybody in and and like
finally enough so I think it started a
very positive trend for Germany so I was
reading on the BBC they had this
international poll Germany is now ranked
number one in terms of like which
country do you think has the most
positive influence in the world
twenty-six countries where Paul Dan and
Germany Zurich one and 55% positives I
think I mean whether it was the World
Cup or what's happening later in the
politics and the economics and all of
that but it's it's it has turned around
I would say that's a significant moment
it really has I just quickly want to ask
you about you've just moved to Frankfurt
why do you leave live there because yes
in your questionnaire you've said this
is my own joke this is no deeds joke the
best thing about Frankfurt is that you
can get out a bit very quickly well I
mean I love Frankfurt obviously but it
is a small city and so sometimes you
want to go on a break and and when the
weather is how it is this year and we're
not having enough summit then it's
amazing that we have you know such a
large airport and well-connected trains
so you enjoy the life it's a good city
because we don't have too many tourists
so you don't have to stumble across the
tourists while getting to work we're
doing your thing so that's quite nice
and it has a quite cosmopolitan feel
because of all the banks and so many
different foreigners coming and it's a
quite nice relaxed vibe to what you have
to discover it but yeah it's sometimes
you need to get out just out of the road
from Frankfurt is the city of Mainz now
that was where in 1455 Johannes
Gutenberg published the first ever book
in the West in the Western world ending
it was the first printed version of the
Bible this is a Gutenberg Bible owned by
the British Library in London the work
is in two volumes with no title page or
page numbers it's the oldest printed
book in the Western world in all 48
copies of this Bible have survived till
today they bear the name Johannes
Gutenberg the inventor of movable type
he printed his Bibles 42 lines to a page
in the German city of Mainz in the mid
15th century
Gutenberg's invention heralded the dawn
of a new era well the big change was the
folks began to move from the world where
they were difficult to get hold off
where they were private and you could
control who got access to them into a
world where it was easy to get access to
books and information for centuries
biblical texts have been translated from
Hebrew into Greek and from Greek into
Latin always copied by hand usually by
monks employ stirs and Abbey's it was an
arduous task Gutenberg printed a hundred
and eighty Bibles at the time each one
just like the next they differed only in
their hand-painted embellishments and
ornamentation in fact the Gutenberg
Bible was the first bestseller all the
Bibles were sold in march 1455 a papal
bureaucrat wrote to his to his Cardinal
who was in charge off and saying that he
had seen the Gooden burg Bible and that
he would have bought a copy for the
Cardinal because it was so good that the
Cardinal could read it without glasses
however they were all sold out today
anyone who wants to can look at
Gutenberg's Bibles because they can be
seen on the internet the gutenberg
website was created in the year 2000
with experts from the keio university in
japan it took three weeks to digitally
scan all the pages about 2,600 in all
now the bible is preserved for posterity
the digital copies it's hoped will
remain long after the parchment and
paper originals have turned to dust
and my guest is a modern-day
typographer Nadine Shaheen and you give
a talk in the gutenberg museum you're
saying and have you actually seen a
Bible yes it was one of the first things
that I did when I came to Germany just
go to the gutenberg museum take a look
at the bible it's just it's it's like
the pilgrimage
it's gorgeous to see and and it's a
must-see for anybody interested in type
and any the history of printing as well
now arabic script is originally very
much associated with the Quran and Islam
so it's just kind of it's a holy script
yes so have you ever been criticized for
dabbling with it if you like or changing
it yes so actually not because what I'm
doing is it's type design which is
basically what we do is in in type
design is is analyze what the skeletal
system is like of each letter how they
are drawn and then you're playing around
with the meat and the muscle around it
but not with the skeletal system so what
we are changing is almost the the form
around the basic skeletal and so we are
not changing what is in the essence of
the script and while you're talking
about this I you because I think we
should have a picture this is from the
the leading Arabic newspaper you've done
it yeah a new scribe dude we just have a
picture yeah exactly so this is for
example the anahata typeface so Gibran
2005 what what you see in in the design
is that it is a very traditional design
it follows the same structure that you
would expect in a newspaper people have
been reading in this style for
essentially already is very well
accepted and then what you do is you we
work on the sculpture it's almost like
if you were going to make a sculpture of
a human figure right you're working with
the overall figure you you're shaping
things but at the end of the day you
have a human figure or not Frankenstein
and that's the difference and type
design it's almost like you it's like a
rubber band there are expectations in
what people think letters should look
like because they have to read them at
the end of the day and sometimes you can
you know
things in a very modern way but you
should never snap that rubberband you
push a little bit you make a little bit
of tension sometimes with typefaces that
are a bit experimental but there is
always the expectations of the public
because they have to read them and there
is also the essence of the script and
that we maintain so there is never a
problem there do you think it's I mean
we've all read and heard a lot about the
Arab Spring things changing so much the
Middle East do you think these sort of
things are improving literacy as well I
hope so I hope so so I when when I did
my PhD the whole topic was about the
legibility of the Arabic script and
which typeface style is more legible and
the whole point of it is for us as
designers to give recommendations for
publishers of books so that people are
hopefully more interested in picking up
a book and reading it because this is
the biggest problem in the Middle East
not just the literacy just the fact that
nobody is reading at all and then you
have problems as we have now with
extremism with lack of education I mean
give them democracy but if they've never
read a book what do they do is democracy
right so you need people to read then
and that's that's what we need to focus
on I want to show one more type face
because you designed the Arab typeface
have had the ones we all know it'll
vesica yeah and fruits again and here
they are I wondered with Helvetica yes
for instance a very famous typeface you
surely they don't surely come to you and
say do what you like now be restrictions
absolutely I mean in terms of
expectations and and so what we're
seeing here is like different typefaces
that I have designed including the
Arabic companion to al vatika and to
flow together and with these typefaces
the Arabic companions it really is a
companion what you do is you analyze the
Latin part you understand what sort of
personality it gives and then you try to
give that same personality in the Arabic
script with a vertical there's the
weight of expectations this is the
typeface of the 20th century this is the
most popular typeface that has ever been
designed and so there's of course the
weight of expectations and and the
pressure that that you have to fulfill
these things but you never know how
things are
it's a big responsibility now on
computers this is going back to the
basic questions now this may be 50 fonts
but most people go for Times New Roman
or Helvetica yeah why is that because
it's there I mean you have to see with
the with the like the traditions of
fonts that have been bundled with the
operating system times for example or
Arial where the default ones so when you
open up a document in Word and Times is
the default some people are not even
aware that you can even change these
things and and so because at first you
had five and then you had 10 and now we
have 50 and in reality there's hundreds
of thousands right fonts so so so it's
it's an issue of lack of awareness and
even when I tell people I design fonts
are like really there are people who
design these things I don't like yeah so
so it's just people not knowing and and
well in fact everything is designed yes
and the public actually feels it and
they react to it even though sometimes
they do not know what they are reacting
to like a newspaper would change the
typeface in Holland for example and then
they would get complaints from the
public why did you change the page but I
can't read it anymore but it wasn't the
paper was the typeface but something
changed and they're not happy about it
and they will be very vocal and they
will complain yeah now I wonder what
about the legal issue here and if I
start a website yes and I'm sitting at
my computer and I'm writing in Times New
Roman or whatever I'm writing in and
maybe my website becomes popular and
takes on adverts yes do I have to pay
the font designer no not if you're using
x no because it's it's bundled with the
system so basically what you are doing
when you're designing the website you're
referencing a font that sits on the
computer of every different user and in
that case you do not need to pay
anything at all so but however in in
recent years we've had the new
technology for web fonts to be able to
decide whichever typeface we would
like to have and use it for our website
so not just times or an vatika or
Verdana and with these typefaces
generally the business models I reliant
on how much traffic you have so if you
suddenly have five million pageviews per
day then yes it changes there across to
that kind of operates a bit like if you
like YouTube in that if you get five
million clicks or something YouTube
gives you some and they can they can
sort this out who's using yeah you can
track at the spite of the service so are
you a very rich woman for doing hell
message are there legal disputes the
business of say you can't use that on
your it's it's it's not it's not a legal
dispute as much as it is a respect for
licensed rights and IP protection and
this is something that Germany is really
good at so for example Germany is one of
the few countries where you can actually
have a design pattern for a typeface and
this is amazingly groundbreaking thing
because even if you go to the US you
don't have that so so it's amazing the
kind of protection we have here in
Germany and so what you would have is
the same like when you have music or
when you have photos you want you want
the protection for the IP and and that's
it we are today bombarded with all sorts
of different lettering in our everyday
lives whether it's DW logos the
different letter fonts on your computer
or the signs at the bus stop they all
influences in some small way
typographers obviously have a special
way of looking at the world and here in
germany one of the Guru's of typography
is Erik Spiekermann
Erik Spiekermann has a passion for fonts
letter fonts that is
the typeface designer is an
internationally acclaimed expert and is
passionate about his work he can't pass
signs of lettering without reading them
his eyes always on the typography
speaker Minh has offices in Berlin as
well as Amsterdam London and San
Francisco
he's behind the corporate design of
German car manufacturer Audi
a few years ago he redesigned The
Economist magazine
since it traded in its old look
for a new one sales have doubled
speaker man's secret to success a good
font is one you don't notice money
second you don't read a typeface you
read a text the medium is as invisible
as air we breathe in continuously but if
we stop to think about it we'd probably
start coughing a font is perceived only
subconsciously back in the 1980s Erik
Spiekermann described how the lettering
on restaurant signs subliminally affects
the viewer the words are written in
spaghetti type or let us spread out like
pizza dough the greeks use angular
letters which remind us of ancient
inscriptions a pub that wants to be seen
as traditional english goes for
old-fashioned lettering and hand-painted
flourishes
one of Erik Spiekermann most prominent
projects was designing fonts for German
rail operator Deutsche Bahn letters with
little individuality but which are
effective due to their familiarity and
Spiekermann has another specialty fonts
which provide orientation after German
unification he developed the signage for
Berlin's transportation network legible
and clear a simple logic and Erik
Spiekermann can get annoyed about bad
fonts for the influential designer this
line of work is very much a labor of
love do you get annoyed by bad fonts oh
yeah yeah okay okay I mean can you give
us an example or well they're more
prominent in the Middle East than they
are here but yeah but that font size
yeah and what do you think of signs and
fonts generally here in Germany positive
about generally yeah I mean the the
level of design in Germany is quite high
and in terms of typefaces and type
designers Germany's digital it's really
good history and a really good you know
contribution why I yeah my bit of
research I was trying to find out about
typefaces and fonts which I knew nothing
about before we started this interview
there seem to be quite a lot of German
designers I mean I mean okay there can
be lots too but yet successful one
absolutely I mean you name it
yeah of course I mean there are two gods
in fact design there's Hermann Zapf
professor Hermann Zapf who is from
Darmstadt here in Germany and Adrian
Frutiger who is just across the border
in Switzerland so also german-speaking
so and these are the two gods of type
design and so this is like the eldest
that we have but you also have now like
really very alive type designs in here
in berlin berlin has made itself into a
type design capital almost today so yeah
if you add a new type designer and you
want to be around other like-minded
young type designers
is the place to be and and that's really
really cool so you have like a ton of
them here one of the one of the most
interesting is Hanna's fangirl
he's also living here he's also worked
with us and he's yeah one of the best
designers today of this why do you think
why do you think the Germans are so good
at that
um I don't know I mean Germans are good
at work that requires a lot of attention
to detail I don't know but it's it's a
tradition and sometimes you have you you
you put the seeds and then there's the
water and the good earth and then they
come and then you build Astra dition and
in Germany has had that tradition and
continues quite good for everybody here
now we have a questionnaire we've
already mentioned your joke about
Frankfurt you did add a couple of extra
ones yourself which I want to come to
very first they're the coolest German
living Manuel Neuer the Bayern Munich
goalkeeper yeah he's really good and
it's in spite of me because I don't
cheer for Bayern but he's a really
really good goalkeeper he like I was
actually hating him for for like doing
such a good job but but he's he's
amazing he's really good yeah yeah okay
now you've added a few extra ones I want
to mention them because we do this every
with every guest and so there's a couple
of new ones best season in Germany thing
why it's the money it's not just that
it's I mean at least in the area where I
live and I know a lot of Germany's like
that as well there's a lot of trees
there's a lot of flowers and then you
you feel the changing of the season
every day just gets a little bit bigger
and bigger and then the flowers come out
and it's just it's just gorgeous
it's absolutely gorgeous and another
category that you added that I think we
should add was the best best kept secret
in Germany yes the countryside I mean
usually what you would say like if
foreigners are coming or tourists you
would go to Berlin you would go to
Munich as always the cities but just get
out of the city and and it's a whole new
world and it's just unbelievably
gorgeous and and it's magical in some
instances I was interested to look at
the
fassl did that castle where all the
tourists go the ocean exactly and and
and we got it and the castle was the
last thing I was looking at because of
the gorgeous countryside the Rolling
Hills a few cows placed here and there
strategically and then the Alps it's
just unbelievably gorgeous unbelievable
and you say the best thing about living
in Germany is a great standard of living
of course
and the worst thing do you remember what
you put was it the weather yeah well the
weather it's summer
yeah exactly exactly in summit yes yes
yes because we have a very long winter
and then the spring is gorgeous and then
it starts to heat up like ah somebody's
coming and then it never comes on and it
rains and then in mid-august it's winter
again like what happened yeah but we're
having we're having some Florida it's
been wonderfully interesting so I don't
know anything about taupe faces a night
I guess many people watching didn't buy
them we've all learnt so much thanks
very much thanks you for watching if
you'd like to write to us type to us do
so an insight at DW dot d ye we'd love
to hear from you we always looking
forward to getting your post and making
your comments about the shows I'll be
back at the same time next week thanks
for watching and bye bye